so as Mike mentioned my name's Michelle
and I'm gonna be talking to you today
about some other work that we're doing
in ophthalmology in informatics and that
is looking at clinic workflows and just
- as you may figure out as we talk that
the probably the biggest difference
between Mike and I is that he is an
ophthalmologist and clinician has a
medical degree I am a computer scientist
so a lot of what I'm gonna be talking
about is much more related to kind of
methods in data science and analysis and
how we can use that to help clinicians
practice medicine
so just you know sort of some units
knowledge and disclosures right at the
beginning our slides but just to orient
you um this is work that we do at KCI
Institute at OHSU and it's got all the
major sub specialties about phonology
has many providers and annual patient
encounters but probably what makes it
the most unique at least in the country
is that it has this dedicated
informatics research Research Center
which as far as I know is pretty unique
I'm not sure and this is our group and
I'm not going to read all of these names
out but it's a big combination of Mike
and I and students from D mice from my
k-ci Institute from the Medical School
and then our interns and so Michael is
working with me this summer
unfortunately what I'm talking about
today isn't very directly related to
what Mike's doing Michaels doing but he
will certainly talk about that later so
you get to hear about that but what I'm
going to be talking about today is the
work that we've been doing and studying
clinical workflows so for those of you
who don't know what a clinical workflow
is or any workflow is is that it's
really just a set of steps or processes
that sort of something has to go through
to to be completed so in this case we're
looking at how what are the steps that a
patient has to go through to complete an
exam in this case it's an ophthalmology
so the steps might be something like
they check
in there they do an initial exam in
ophthalmology that's done by a
technician who does you know get started
on the visual exam or the eye exam and
then the physician comes in completes
the exam and and then they're checked
out now the one thing that is a part of
all of these steps as you might notice
is the computer and electronic health
record there's all this interaction with
the electronic health record and that's
going to become important as we talk
about how we study this so but first of
all we want to talk about why do we even
study this in the first place so we're
studying workflows is really about
studying the efficiency of them and
efficiency is important because it can
affect patient satisfaction so it's an
inefficient clinic you can have high
wait times and it can make patients
upset and and not come back or not want
to get their care there go somewhere
else I can accept it can affect finances
because if we're not seeing as many
patients as you could you could be
losing out in some income but it can
also affect provider burnout if they
were doing a lot of extra steps or
things are taking real a long time and
that provider burnout is a very hot
topic right now but the challenge is how
do we study this so you know in the past
it's kind of the simple ways of doing
this would be for people to go in person
and observe what the clinicians are
doing maybe take some timing data as
well but the problem with this is that
it's expensive because it's labor
intensive it's time consuming and it's a
very limited scale so you might be able
to do an observation but it would be for
you know very particular you know clinic
at that particular time and it wouldn't
capture changes that might happen over
time or that might be different between
different providers or clinics so we
really wanted to find a better more
robust way to study these workflows so
this is where the EHR comes in and the
secondary use of the data that's within
the EHR and I think by now all of you
know that the EHR just contains all
sorts of data about patients they come
in there's things that are recorded
during their clinical exams there's
result there's lab results there's
medications there's
sorts of things and a lot of times when
people talk about secondary use of EHR
data they're talking more about how do
we use data that was required clinical
data that was recorded to somehow
improve clinical care and what we're
going to be looking at instead what we
call audit log data so audit log data is
data that stored in the HR but it's
collected as people use the EHR and
there are regulations that require EHRs
to log things about EHR use so you need
to know you know for example who looked
at a chart for what patient
and these audit logs look like this it
records the time that you know there was
some sort of interaction who did it you
know for what patient and there's
usually a context like for what people
report visit were they doing this what
they were doing in the HR and where what
computer were they on now there can be
different granularities in terms of how
many entries you have how often those
entries show up in the audit log data
those are different options there's also
some variation in terms of what this
data looks like depending on who your HR
vendor is but in any case there are just
billions of entries in the EHR about all
this logs and it really is a significant
majority of the data that's actually
stored within the EHR so being able to
mine this to do our studies would be
fantastic so this is sort of a graphic
that represents sort of a pictorial view
might look at our timeline looking at
how those audit log entries happen and I
have to thank my postdoc Adam for
creating this it's graphic so each one
of those little vertical slashes
represents an auto log entry so there's
a whole bunch of data there you know
according to that or you know
corresponding to that so there's the the
time there's you know who did it what
patient what visit you know what
computer and you can see here that this
is just sort of an example for one
provider and you and it's divided up
into which patient they were working on
and then you can kind of see over time
how all these these entries kind of line
up so then we can do different things
with them so the first thing is we're
going to look at the exam times so using
contextual data about our patient we
know when they're checked in we know you
know which workstations are you know
clinic exam rooms we can actually
identify okay so these timestamps
happened here we think this is when they
had an exam and we can figure out when
the first and last one was and say okay
so that's how long we think their exam
happened so this gives us a way of
measuring exam times for many many
patients for many providers overtime
which is great it allows us to do a lot
of different things so I'm going to talk
through kind of a lot of different
topics of ways that we've uses so one is
we've used them as part of a discrete
event simulation model and so these are
just models that help us they can model
any workflow they ever started actually
for manufacturing but anything that can
be divided up into steps and so for each
step we have to know essentially a
distribution of how long that stuff is
going to take and what resources they
need so in our case we use the audit log
data to generate distributions of exam
times that each of our exam steps took
we also had distributions from the EHR
on when patients arrived a relative to
their scheduled time so we could
generate those distributions as well and
then we can run these simulations based
on different parameters in this case we
were testing how scheduling affected
things so then that scheduling sort of
affected how those patients arrived and
for the different schedules we're able
to measure you know according to the
simulation how much patients would have
waited so um for scheduling what we're
trying to do is we're trying to mitigate
those kind of really busy and slow
periods and clinics we're trying to kind
of create a steady stream of patients as
much as we can so that we can minimize
wait time and we know from the
literature from prior research that
scheduling according to length and
variability can really help even out
those times so we used simulation to
kind of see what happens when they have
long patient encounters or long offices
it's and where do we put them in the
clinic day so we put them at the
beginning so if that's at block one
which is to the right of here what does
the wait time look like versus as we
start moving it you know each block down
you know the clinic day and so if you
get to the end all the way to the right
that would be at the end of the clinic
day and you can see that the blue line
represents what they average wait time
wasn't it does go down but the orange
line represents the clinic length and
you can see that it does actually
increase and so clinic managers had been
scheduling paid long patients at the
beginning and they decided okay looking
at this maybe we need to start moving or
a long patients closer to the end of the
clinic so we can you know mitigate that
patient wait time and what happens is
when the long patients are at the
beginning is that you just get behind
them and it just gets worse sooner so
what we did was we actually separated
patients into short medium and long
categories and then scheduled them
according to that with the short ones at
the beginning meet him in the beginning
in the middle and then we didn't put
long at the very end because we didn't
want them extending into lunch or at the
end of the day we implemented this in
all pediatric ophthalmology clinics and
through now the physicians are helping
us categorize the patients the
courageous short meeting even long and
when we implemented this in our initial
clinic we really decreased the average
patient wait time and at the same time
it just so happened that the provider
was increasing their volumes so even
though that they increase the volume on
average over one patient per clinic we
still managed to decrease their average
wait time which was pretty good
we rolled it out into the rest of the
providers in Pediatrics they all were
able to increase their clinic volume
without increasing their patient wait
times and most of them actually
decreased it the only one that didn't
actually increase their patient volume
by quite a bit
so that was one way of using it the
other way is now we're looking at how do
we predict these exam times we were
using providers but can we do a better
job because now we have thousands we
have potentially data about
thousands of exams that we can't get
from the HR using the audit logs and can
we use machine learning and cannot do
better than providers so we used the
prior exam links along with some other
features about the patients and the
exams and we found that we had 65
percent accuracy in terms of categorize
them short medium and long using machine
learning whereas the providers were only
about 42% accurate and we're still
working on ways to improve their
accuracy but we're hoping that that's
going to help us with this and actually
make our results even better if we can
schedule patients or be able to predict
how long they're going to take and
schedule them cleanly and then the next
way that we've used these audit logs is
it's just a slight variation of this and
it is looking at just when it just at
the different time or the different
minutes that we have EHR use and it's
not a perfect way of measuring each our
use but it's the best one we have so we
just say if you use the HR in this
minute then you know that was time spent
on the EHR and we can count that so now
we can potentially use this to measure
EHR time use for you know providers over
a wide variety of settings including at
home where observation really isn't it
not possibility so we were able to do
this in ophthalmology so this is total
EHR use both in clinic and out of clinic
and we actually categorize it as well
whether it was a way that's directly
related to patient visit versus other
things like inbox measuring and that
sort of thing
and this just sort of shows that that
providers are consistently using the HR
really at least half of their day some
of them even more and we think this is
an underestimate
so this EHR is really predominating in
their work and not only that but we were
able to see over time how this has
changed so at OHSU we started using an
EHR in 2006 so we looked at 10 years of
use
you can see that it increased and we
were able to actually sort of corley
that and I shouldn't use a Recor like
that line that up with when meaningful
use the different forms of meaningful
use happened and you can see that there
was a big bump in the amount of time
that providers were using the HR for the
different meaningful use stages but it
looks like it's kind of stabilizing and
we're studying that right now in terms
of what how people are using it and why
you know it might be becoming more
efficient or maybe leveling off and
finally the one of the ways we've used
this to measure this documentation time
is we were able to use and see what the
impact of scribes is on provider
documentation time so we were able to
show that in the patient appointment
obviously providers aren't using the EHR
as much because subscribe is using the
EHR but this graph shows you what
happens after the visit and you can pour
seven of our ophthalmology providers
four of them actually spent more time on
average using the EHR after the visit
then when they didn't have a scribe and
three of them actually used it less but
this is an important kind of an
important result because one of the
reasons that people use scribes is to
kind of avoid burnout and if you're
still having to do more work after the
exam especially at home those are the
things that have been tied to burn out
that scribes might not be the perfect
answer for that so that's a paper that
is coming out soon and then finally the
last way that we've been using this or
at least I'm going to talk about is not
only looking at time but looking at what
people are looking at in the HR so as I
mentioned before each one of those
flashes because give us information
about you know what patient what
provider it also gives us information
about what visit so we can look at these
reviews and be able to see how many
prior offices that notes how many other
encounters did a provider look at during
the course of an exam so so we can
actually sort of determine what users
are look at kind of what they're doing
in the EHR without direct observation so
this is what we found out so there's
some variation here but on general in
general we looked at orange is these are
prior offices at notes and the blue bars
represent non offices at notes so they
be things like lab results and you can
see that an average it's about three
notes per visit are reviewed half of
them are offices that's half of them
aren't it varies quite a bit by provider
in terms of how many are reviewed and we
think this relates to both the limited
time that providers have but also the
design the EHR and how easier hard it is
to actually do review of prior notes in
electronic health record and this is
also spurring some additional research
into how to make this HR more efficient
and how to provide better provide or
manage or support I should say the
information needs providers the time
care so but there are some limitations
to this type of analysis and using audit
log data our workflow time estimates and
the document each time may not be
accurate so our exam times might not
actually correspond may not begin or end
with the HRU so then we don't have any
capture of that full time we also kind
of rely on the fact that we know which
workstations are you know our exam room
so we can actually identify which
timestamps happen during the exam but
when providers use laptops then we can't
do that
also the gaps in time are really
difficult to interpret we don't know if
a gap in time especially in exam is
because the provider stopped using the
EHR and is now examining the patient is
but still with the patient or if they
got called all of the room right maybe
they had a phone call emergency and they
left so um you know it can be difficult
to interpret the granularity of each our
time stamps can be limited especially in
a large scale so when a provider for
example is writing a note that often
generates just one timestamp and we
don't know we don't have a beginning and
so we don't know if there if there's a
gap that they wrote if they have the
timestamp that said okay I'm writing a
note and we had another timestamp two
hours later or whatever were they
writing the note that whole time or
we're you know they all go off and do
something else and come back so it can
really make it difficult to interpret
some things but it's also an incomplete
record of EHR use so the audit log will
only require things that are done within
the EHR it won't record things like for
example in ophthalmology there's often
looking at images and we don't have any
record because it's a separate system so
we have to get access to that to get
those kind of that kind of data but in
summary I've shown you essentially you
know how we use out a log data in three
different ways that we've managed to do
this it allows for really large scale
studies that wouldn't be possible in
person but it's also become a really
popular source for data for doing
studies and I'm actually part of a
national research network of audit log
users and I'm managing a group right now
that is trying to define the measures
that audit that you can create from
audit log measure or all that like data
to try and standardize and make them
more reproducible so for example if I
said I you know did this study audit log
shows that our Doc's spend this much
time using the EHR that someone would be
able to go out at their own institution
and repeat that study for their own
institution their own doctors so we can
actually start to make some meaningful
comparisons so that's just sort of a
summary of what I do and it's as you can
tell a little bit more data focused but
it's still related to clinical care so
for those of you who are might be a
little bit more interested in the
computer or data side of things as
opposed to being involved directly
involved in clinical care this is a
really excellent opportunity for very
very interesting sort of rich sources of
data and being
to do really interesting types of an elf
so at this point I don't know if there's
any questions and you can ask questions
of me or my kit let's wait
so you talked about some of the
uncertainties and using the audit log
data so how would you validate that
that's a really good question and one of
the other things I should mention too is
that as part of this workgroup well it's
not really part of the worker but Adam
is actually working on a review paper of
all the literature and all the studies
in polish using audit log data and
validation is actually something that is
not reported on very reliably and there
are very few studies that validated it
we're one of the few groups that has
validated it or try attempted to n even
then it's showing us that it's not
perfect so we've actually gone and done
in-person studies and then looked at the
audit logs and line them up and said
okay in this case it's about you know
it's up to one or three minutes
difference when you're looking at
something like documentation time where
you're only using it for three minutes
if you're off by a minute that's a big
percentage right if you're talking about
exam times which might be more on the
order of you know 10 or 11 minutes then
that is different one of the things that
that the vendors are doing at least from
what they're reporting in the the work
groups that I'm working on is they're
trying to come up with better
granularity of results so that we have
more data and we can so we're not just
having a single entry for each action so
we can have a better sense of when that
begins and ends so that we can improve
that granularity and ability it's a
little bit better but that's a really
good question it's one of the challenges
that we're working on and trying to come
up with our recommendations for
in terms of the validation that Michelle
had done it was basically that I know
you talked a little bit about a series
of several hundred about 400 encounters
that there were sort of what we'd call
gold standard data which was somebody
following a doctor and a patient around
with an iPad and logging what they
actually did and then comparing it with
these audit log scores and the short
answers that it works like pretty well
except when it doesn't and you know when
it doesn't is basically when doctors
like Michelle was saying when they don't
do that standard workflow they log in
before the patient showed up or they
okay and then you know that's when you
get those errors but probably 70 percent
of time it's it's within you know
roughly a minute or two of the actual
time yeah and one of our challenges of
course is validating it for use at home
and so we can do self-reported data from
that we tried that and that was just we
thought okay we'll just have them record
and that was really really off it didn't
work at all so we're still trying and we
were just discussing it I mean this
morning what how you could potentially
validate that better and how much of
this is just waiting for better
granularity or better reporting from the
vendors
any other questions
for variable devices for validating
workflow processes and validating audit
log data with using wearable devices
yeah and in fact that is something we've
looked into there with actually more
problems with the data that we got from
the wearable devices then there was with
the autoblog data there was a lot of
problems with interference and trying to
figure out exactly where you were it
tracks things differently I have seen
work done by another group in
ophthalmology at the University of
Michigan where there have been using
RFID trapping to try and to do these
timings and locations and they their
accuracy is something like 60 to 70
percent accurate for what they've been
able to figure out so it's not any
better than the audit log data so using
it as a way to validate audit log data
isn't necessarily great either
so yeah there's just limitations to this
the the one thing that is a possibility
that you could do is turn on there's
options for turning on a much higher
annual arity of essentially it's
recording everything you're doing like
all the keystrokes this stuff so that
you could potentially get a little bit
better accuracy and try and figure out
you know what were you really doing and
then if you're not looking at every
single time stamp you know how close are
we getting because we you can't have
that turned on all the time because it's
just too much data so that's another
possibility and things that people are
talking about doing in terms of
validation
all right well thank you for coming and
good luck to all of you
[Applause]